>>> MOST EYES AND ATTENTION THIS
WEEK WERE ON THE MISSILE THAT
LANDED IN POLAND JUST OVER THE
BOARDER FROM UKRAINE ON TUESDAY.
BUT THE UNITED STATES DOES NOT
BELIEVE RUSSIA FIRED THAT
MISSILE.
WHAT WE ALL SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PAYING ATTENTION TO WAS THE
DEVASTATING AERIAL BOMBARDMENT
OF UKRAINE THAT MOSCOW DELIVERED
THIS WEEK.
THE BRITISH MINISTRY OF DEFENSE
SAID THERE WAS THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF STRIKES THAT RUSSIA
HAS CONDUCTED IN A SINGLE DAY
SINCE THE FIRST WEEK OF THE
INVASION.
ONE OF THE MAIN TARGETS HAS BEEN
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE, PLUNGING
SWATHS OF UKRAINIANS INTO
DARKNESS.
KYIV EXPERIENCED BLACKOUTS AND
COMMUNICATION DISRUPTIONS, ALL
THIS AS WINTER, COLD, AND SNOW
HAVE ARRIVED.
LET ME BRING IN THE PANEL TO
TALK ABOUT UKRAINE AND WE'LL
LATER GET TO CHINA.
JOINING ME IS RICHARD HAASS AND
TIM NAFTALI.
RICHARD IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
COUNCIL ON FOREIGN RELATIONS,
AND TIM IS A CNN PRESIDENTIAL
HISTORIAN AND TEACHES HISTORY AT
NYU.
SO THAT BOMBARDMENT, THIS IS
PART OF THE NEW GENERAL THAT'S
BEEN PUT IN PLACE IN RUSSIA.
THIS IS THE GUY WHO OVERSAW THE
SYRIAN CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT HE DID IN
SYRIA.
IT IS BRUTAL.
AND THEY'RE GOING FOR ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE, THEY'RE
BASICALLY PLUNGING THE CIVILIAN
POPULATION INTO COLD AND MISERY,
RIGHT?
CAN UKRAINE JUST KEEP TAKING
THESE BODY BLOWS?
>> YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THIS IS THE ALEPPO PART OF THE
UKRAINE WAR.
RUSSIA WENT COMPETE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD, SO THEY'RE SAYING
WE ARE GOING TO SO INCREASE THE
MISERY, THAT WE ARE GOING TO TRY
TO GET YOU TO SHUT "UNAC"UNCLE"E
CAN CLAIM THIS WAS WORTH IT.
MASS BOMBING TENDING TO STIFFEN
THE SPINE OF CIVILIAN
POPULATIONS, BUT WE'LL SEE.
HE'S HOPING THE NEW HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES HERE MIGHT GIVE
HIM A BREAK.
HE'S HOPING EUROPEANS GET COLD
THIS WINTER, MAYBE THEY'LL LOSE
THEIR SPIRIT OF BACKING UKRAINE.
AND OBVIOUSLY HE WANTS TO BREAK
THE BACK OF THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL WORK, BUT
THAT RIGHT NOW IS HIS STRATEGY.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> OH, IT'S ABSOLUTELY HIS
STRATEGY.
HE IS LOOKING FOR WEAKNESS, FOR
LACK OF RESOLVE ON THE PART OF
EUROPEANS AND THE UNITED STATES.
AND LIKE ALL AUTOCRATS, HE
UNDERESTIMATES DEMOCRACIES.
ONE THING YOU CAN COUNT ON FROM
AN AUTOCRAT, THEY THINK WE ARE
WEAK AND ALWAYS GET SURPRISED
WHEN WE DON'T BACK DOWN.
SO WE HAVE TO PROJECT A SENSE OF
UNITY AND RESOLVE.
>> WHICH WE HAVE SO FAR BEEN
ABLE TO DO, ROIGHT?
>> REMARKABLY SO.
THE UNITED STATES AND EUROPE
HAVE TOLD PUTIN WE MEAN IT WHEN
WE WANT TO DEFEND UKRAINIAN
SOVEREIGNTY.
>> BUT IT DOES HIGHLIGHT THAT
UKRAINE IS GOING TO BE
DEVASTATED.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN COME UP
WITH A FIGURE TO DESCRIBE WHAT
THE REBUILDING OF UKRAINE IS
GOING TO COST AT THIS STAGE.
>> IT'S INCALCULABLE.
IT'S POLARIZATION.
THIS IS A MODERN SOCIETY.
WE'VE BOTH SPENT TIME THERE.
YOU GO TO DOWNTOWN KYIV AND YOU
COULD HAVE BEEN IN ANY MODERN
CITY IN CONTEMPORARY EUROPE.
THE COST OF THIS, A QUARTER OF
THE POPULATION HAS BEEN
DISPLACED.
THE PHYSICAL COST NOW.
I SPOKE TO A FRIEND THE OTHER
DAY IN KYIV.
I THINK SHE IS ON THE 23rd FLOOR
OF HER BUILDING.
THE ONLY WAY TO GET TO HER
APARTMENT IS TO WALK UP AND DOWN
THE STAIRS.
IMAGINE WHAT THIS IS LIKE FOR
THE ELDERLY AND FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN.
SO THIS IS A CONSCIOUS STRATEGY.
THESE ARE WAR CRIMES ON AN
HOURLY BASIS.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE SEEING.
AND THE COST OF REBUILDING
UKRAINE, THE YEARS IT WILL TAKE,
THE DOLLARS IT WILL TAKE, WILL
BE ENORMOUS.
>> TIM, YOU HAD A FASCINATING
PIECE IN FOREIGN AFFAIRS THAT
YOU POINTED OUT PUTIN, IN A
CONFERENCE WITH A BUNCH OF
RUSSIAN JOURNALISTS, IN ANSWER
TO ONE OF HIS FAVORITE FOREIGN
POLICY EXPERTS, WHO HAS BEEN ON
THIS SHOW, THE GUY ASKED HIM
ABOUT THE CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS.
AND WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> HE ASKED PUTIN, ARE YOU GOING
TO BE LIKE KHRUSHCHEV, ACCEPTING
A RETREAT?
AND PUTIN --
>> HE SAID ARE YOU GOING TO BE
LIKE KHRUSHCHEV, AND PUTIN SAYS,
YOU MEAN, ACCEPT A RETREAT?
NO.
>> WHAT'S SO IMPORTANT IS THAT
THERE IS A SENSE AMONG AMERICAN
AND SOME EUROPEAN ELITES THAT
THE CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS ENDED
PEACEFULLY BECAUSE OF
STATESMANSHIP ON BOTH SIDES.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT
STATESMANSHIP MATTERED.
BUT THE INITIAL MOVE TOWARDS AN
OFF RAMP WAS FROM THE RUSSIAN
AND THE SOVIET SIDE.
THE RUSSIANS WERE SCARED.
THE REASON THEY WERE SCARED IS
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR SOME LACK
OF RESOLVE ON THE PART OF JOHN
F. KENNEDY AND THEY DIDN'T SEE
IT.
WHEN JOHN F. KENNEDY IMPOSED A
BLOCKADE AND STUCK BY ID, C
KHRUSHCHEV REALIZED, I DON'T
WANT WAR.
SO DON'T LOOK TO HISTORY TO GIVE
PUTIN A REASON FOR AN OFF RAMP.
DON'T GIVE PUTIN A SENSE YOU
WANT TO END THIS, BECAUSE HE'S
DESPERATE FOR STRAWS.
FORCE HIM TO WANT AN OFF RAMP
THE WAY THAT JOHN F. KENNEDY
FORCED KHRUSHCHEV TO LOOK FOR AN
OFF RAMP.
>> BUT KHRUSHCHEV ACTED YOU
BELIEVED GREATER RESTRAINT.
THERE WAS A DEGREE OF
INSTITUTIONS IN THE SOVIET
UNION.
YOU HAD A DEGREE OF COLLECTIVE
LEADERSHIP.
WE HAVE A PERSONALIZATION AND A
DE-INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF THAT
COUNTRY, WHICH MAKES IT
FRIGHTENING THAT ONE MAN HAS SO
MUCH POWER.
>> BUT WE SHOULDN'T BE SEARCHING
FOR OFF RAMPS FOR PUTIN, WE
SHOULD BE MAINTAINING PRESSURE
AND LET HIM LOOK FOR THE OFF
RAMPS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
NEITHER SIDE IS PREPARED TO
ACCEPT HALF A LOAF.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS CREATE THE
CONDITIONS FOR DIPLOMACY RATHER
THAN GO DIRECTLY INTO DIPLOMACY.